américa latina enfrenta varios desafíos
para acceder a la vacuna con alrededor
de 630 millones de habitantes y un vasto
territorio con zonas recónditas y
algunas veces impenetrables no sólo el
acceso a dichas regiones es un problema
sino también la conservación de la
inyección ya que la mayoría de las
vacunas debe ser almacenada a bajas
temperaturas lo que supone un problema
para su traslado
uno tiene que ser cuidadoso en la
elección de una vacuna porque es bueno
para su demografía word
e instalaciones disponen en el país
cuánto pueden almacenarla y cómo pueden
distribuirla méxico tiene por delante
uno de los mayores retos con casi 130
millones de habitantes es el segundo
país más poblado de latinoamerica para
ello su gobierno ha elaborado un plan
para vacunar a 10 millones de personas
cada mes de forma gratuita para
diciembre de 2021 brasil comenzará con
la inmunización del personal sanitario
los adultos mayores e indígenas sin
embargo no es claro cuándo empezará a
hacerlo confía en alcanzar este objetivo
en virtud del acuerdo firmado con la
farmacéutica británica astrazéneca a la
que compró 100 millones de dosis y la
tecnología para producirla en su
territorio sin embargo este acuerdo no
garantiza una total distribución sobre
todo para la población de las zonas más
remotas del país colombia tiene
asegurados 20 millones de dosis para sus
casi 50 millones de habitantes empezarán
por grupos de riesgo y los adultos
mayores
autoridades ya han reconocido que la
mayoría de la población no se podrá
vacunar hasta el 2022 el gobierno
peruano está convencido de que podrá
recibir las dosis suficientes de la
vacuna en el primer trimestre del 2021
las elecciones generales de abril